Our schooling came within the live work that
presented the stuff. Then we actually got
better so as more opportunities came.
All right, well, I'm going to embrace this.
I'm going to knock it out. But you became a
well oiled machine because you got reps.
You got practice. I can cry on the spot.
Can you? Yes, I on a spot.
Let me see.
Want to do it? Let me see.
You want to see it? Yeah. All right.
You better f***ing buckle up.
Let me see. Here it comes.
You look like- they have the air on.
Yeah. You look like you're having, like a
seizure.
No. Okay. Does this look like a seizure?
Are you ready for this?
Now you look constipated.
No, no, because you didn't let me finish.
Okay, finish.
I don't want to do it. Listen, what would I
do?
Well, anyways, I don't didn't think I knew
how to do it.
You can do it.
And I know now that I can do it.
Because you did it. Because you put yourself
in a situation. You put yourself in a
situation, you're going to cry because
you're acting.
I'm not a crier person.
I am a little bit weird, like I.
I don't cry that much.
I am, yes.
Yeah. And and I was very, very, very worried
that I was not going to be able to cry.
Can I give you a true story?
Like. Seriously? I'm joking around about
playing like, oh yeah, I can cry and just
joking now because.
You can't cry.
Well, I'm going to give you can you f***ing
listen to my story?
But can you cry or not cry?
I'm about to f***ing tell you.
Okay. Tell me.
Okay. Go ahead, go on.
I'm trying. Okay.
All right, so we did the this movie
fatherhood right.
And fatherhood story about me with this
little girl father who had overcome trials
and tribulations of taking on the
responsibility of fatherhood while not
having the means to do it.
Okay. My wife died at delivery and oh my
God, my life.
Right? Okay. And the first scene, I'm with
Alfre Woodard and this is like day 12 of the
movie, maybe, and the whole shoot.
I'm thinking about this day because of Alfre
Woodard, and I'm like, I know where she's
coming in at, and I need to make sure on
this day I'm prepared.
And I really I just, I didn't know.
And I said, if I don't get lost in the
scene, I'm not going to be able to pull it
off. And on the day.
On the actual f***ing day.
I told the director, I said, can you start
off close and we get it?
And then as we get wide, we know that we got
it, because I don't know how many times I'm
going to be able to get it.
And I said, I have to get lost in the world
of what Alfred does.
Yeah. Because I know how she's going to come
in. And I really waited to see what Alfred's
performance was in the scene.
Alfred's performance made me f***ing cry.
All of my tears came from what she did.
Her reaction to her daughter dying is what
made me as the husband cry.
Because I was in the hallway trying to be
strong. And so the mother presented herself.
Yeah, but those are things like, for example,
don't you think that they teach them in
acting class? Yes, but we don't know those
things.
So we have to find a cheat sheet.
So it's like crazy.
That was my cheat sheet. For-- your cheat
sheet?
Cheat sheet. Like, in other words, that's
what I use. I didn't want to say that.
I didn't want to voice that, but I was like,
Chichi.
You didn't want a Cheat.
Sheet.
Oh, cheat sheet.
Don't.
Don't. Didn't f***ing say it like that.
I thought you said Chichi.
No cheat.
Sheet. Okay, that's how I cheated.
God damn it! You want me to say it?
I f***ing cheated, Sofia.
I mean, that's what she's trying to get me
to say that I cheated.
You think you're slick?
She wants me to say I cheated.
Fine, I cheated.